dans un mois c'est noël et les communes
sont à pied d'oeuvre pour installer les
dernières décorations à coignières 110
installations ont été montés par les
agents municipaux coût total dix mille
euros pour la municipalité à coignières
nous maîtrisons en totalité la révision
des décorations de noël la création
également et la pause ce qui nous permet
de bien maîtriser de a à z à un coût
tout à fait raisonnable et encore une
fois de qualité grâce aux ateliers
municipaux qui oeuvre en permanence là
dessus aux clayes-sous-bois
l'installation est externalisée
illuminations sur la mairie et les
lampadaires boules de neige dans les
arbres ou encore 80 sapins sont répartis
dans les rues de la ville des points de
vue financier on a diminué entre 2011
nous étions aux environs de 50000 euros
qu'on investisse et maintenant on a
diminué on est plus qu à 40000 euros
autre économie on a plus de lampes
incandescentes on n'a que des leds les
différentes décorations on les choisit
en fonction des lieux où on voit les
poser quand on a une zone alors on a
ciblé les zones commerciales pour mettre
en valeur les commerces surtout dans
cette période festive de noël
le lancement des illuminations aux
clayes-sous-bois se fera le 5 décembre
et à partir du 16 une patinoire sera
ouverte sur le parvis de la mairie